we are right now joined by magnus
crossing ready for semi-finals
congratulations magnus thank you now
could i ask you together with david and
the analysis board to
take us through this final game it was
crazy to us
yeah uh i i guess i was outplayed
at some point and uh i certainly
certainly was
uh was lost uh but
um somehow i managed to to get out of it
uh yeah i'd seen that knight c4 one on
one on the spot but
what could i do yeah by now i guess the
pawns are just running through
um magnus was this game do you think it
was just down to the opening i mean
already around here we thought it was
very difficult for black to even find a
move
um or i mean was that was the opening
kind of affected by the match situation
um
uh yeah sure
um he sort of surprised me there and i i
couldn't
couldn't really find a uh good
good response at all um he surprised you
at what point sorry
no i already early on by playing
rook d1 he sort of confused me with the
move order there
um and i mean i
i decided just to to improvise but i i
don't think it was was very good uh
what i i did probably
while i had the chance i needed to
to take the the bishop pair or
take his other bishop by checking on e3
because what i got in the game was just
very
very unpleasant and then um
yeah i mean knight d4 was actually um
when i did that was actually just a a
blunder um since i
i'd just missed that he could uh go
bishop c5 and take an extra pawn
this way i was just considering f5
probably that is good as well um
okay so in this position knight d4
yeah yeah with some miscalculation so
that was um yeah it wasn't wasn't very
good
very good um today in general i felt
like i i played
played a lot worse than i did the the
other days um
but uh yeah fortunately i got uh got the
job done
so minus right now is sort of the
overwhelming feeling that you're a
little bit disappointed with this game
or
is it that you actually i mean basically
you won two you could have won three
games yesterday
another win today and fantastic
preliminaries
no sure um i just uh
need to um to sort of pull myself
together um tomorrow because i need to
play a bit better than
than i did today but
obviously like um the worst moment for
me today was
that i could could have lost lost the
game which
meant that i would have had to draw on
demand uh
with with white in the last game so uh
in that sense it wasn't
wasn't bad at all um but um
certainly certainly not quite as good as
the as the other days
i know your father has said this magnus
is it uh maybe
people on my sort of chess level and and
definitely below your level is it
a common misunderstanding that it's it's
easy to draw on demand is it harder to
draw on the man
than what we think yeah i think
i mean i think it as white it shouldn't
be very
very difficult although i have lost some
games
there as well um
but yeah it's i think
these most win games are very very tense
for
for both sides and frankly i don't
particularly enjoy being on either side
of them
well it is yana pomnyacchi now were you
in the semi-finals that's i mean i'm
very excited about that how do you feel
about it
now it's gonna it's gonna be a good
match up um
i think he he started out really poorly
in the
preliminaries and then caught fire
towards
the end um and uh
i thought today he was he was very
impressive
so uh that's yeah certainly going to be
be a great uh match-up yeah uh magnus
you've known yan
i mean since you were kids i guess and
you've played each other countless times
um are you allowed to give us any
insight into how you'll be approaching
those games
i think the
the most important thing is not to give
him
um
well first of all to pose him some
problems in the openings i guess and
then
uh not to to let him have
sort of easy play where you can where
you can just
uh play quit play quickly with little
tactical
tricks all the time something that he
does extremely well
well finally magnus in the champions
chester have you ever felt
better about your play heading into the
semi-finals
again i would say today wasn't wasn't
great if you'd asked me
yesterday no um
but uh no overall uh
this is even with today this is
obviously a
massive step up from from the last few
tournaments
alright we wish you the best of luck
tomorrow magnus thanks for joining
thank you